questa toilette dall'aspetto così
turistico a una seduta riscaldata un
sistema di auto pulizia e mette una
fragranza ogni utilizzo una melodia
addirittura un jet all'interno tipo b
day tutto controllato da un'app sullo
smartphone
fantastico no ci sono addirittura idee
per rendere ancora più utile con le
prossime versioni magari aggiungere un
controllo un analisi delle urine
all'interno potrà quindi dirvi se avete
un infezione in corso potrà calcolare il
vostro tasso alcolemico magari proporvi
la ricetta di un beverone dopo sbornia
sull'iphone per la mattina dopo potrà
addirittura dire siete incinta suonare
la cavalcata delle valchirie potrà
registrare gli ormoni della gravidanza
addirittura nella versione attuale c'è
nell'app un calendario mi potete
registrare la vostra regolarità
intestinale
cioè mi stupisce che non abbiano messo
una bilancia all'interno così potrete
sfidare magari gli amici su facebook
ogni utilizzo io non so quanti di voi
correranno comprerà comprare subito
questa toilette di sicuro tutte le donne
in sala che convivono con un uomo perché
c'è anche una funzione utilissima e
quando ci si allontana abbassa
automaticamente la tavoletta per
benvenuti nell internet of things che
riesce a metter fine anche alle terne
liti coniugali ma cos'è questo internet
of things l'internet delle cose
l'internet delle cose la connettività di
ogni oggetto in ogni momento e in ogni
luogo 50 miliardi di dispositivi saranno
connessi a internet entro i prossimi
cinque anni
noi sono tutti questi dispositivi le
nostre case magari intorno a noi addosso
a noi addirittura magari dentro di noi
sono dei sensori che misurano i livelli
di pressione di ossigeno all'interno del
corpo
questi vengono ingeriti e poi vengono
assorbiti dall'organismo quindi
comunicano i dati all'esterno con con i
medici dati diagnostici sono addirittura
defibrillatori che comunicano i dati con
i medici all'esterno
oppure pensate ai sistemi che
controllano le infrastrutture critiche
di intere nazioni centrali elettriche
cartelli stradali intelligenti connessi
tra loro semafori intelligenti oppure
anche nelle automobili case
automobilistiche sono sempre più attenti
a queste cose inseriscono la
connettività all'interno di tutte le
automobili ormai ci sono sistemi di
diagnostica dei pneumatici del
tachimetro controlli della velocità
controlli dello sterzo controlli dei
freni ci sono addirittura case che
aggiornano la centralina a distanza via
internet magari la casa madre in
germania sta aggiornando le auto vendute
negli stati uniti di notte mentre solo
nel garage sono poi applicazioni sul
telefono che vi fanno vedere come state
guidando i nostri consumi il vostro
stile di guida oppure avviciniamoci un
po qualcosa che nelle nostre case per
esempio quanti di voi hanno una smart tv
una televisione che permette di vedere
un video su internet o ascoltare una
canzone su youtube oppure una netcomm
sono sempre più diffuse le net che vi
permettono di vedere sul cellulare cosa
avviene nella stanza del vostro bambino
al piano di sopra
oppure guardare cosa fa il vostro cane
mentre siete in ufficio
vederlo che mangia il divano
scodinzolando e noi siamo in ufficio
impotenti non pensate che questi oggetti
sono così lontani dalla realtà perché
alla fine quando voi cambierete la
televisione o la lavatrice facile che
questa sia connessa internet perché
ormai tutti i nuovi dispositivi hanno
questo tipo di funzioni sempre in alcune
case ci sono per esempio termostati
intelligenti connesse a internet questi
termostati sanno tramite il cellulare
dove ci troviamo
se stiamo andando verso l'ufficio se
stiamo tornando a casa in quale stanza
siamo cambiano la temperatura delle
stanze di conseguenza oppure le bilance
che mandano i dati di fitness sui nostri
profili online sono addirittura dei
giovani italiani che hanno inventato il
materasso intelligente un coprimaterasso
in realtà che impara come dormiamo le
nostre abitudini sa quando deve scaldare
quale parte di letto che ora addirittura
questi dispositivi misurano anche come
dormiamo si possono anche dire se stiamo
russando per esempio e ai russato questa
notte non è vero lo dice il materasso ok
il pericolo di ci dica anche con chi
abbiamo dormito li vedo tante facce
preoccupate
alla fine io però non vi ho detto ancora
chi sono io mi chiamo stefano sono
almeno dieci giorni che non compro un
nuovo dispositivo elettronico di questo
tipo sono dipendente dalla tecnologia
tendo a riempirmi di questi oggetti però
nel mio lavoro mi occupo di sicurezza ed
insicurezza cioè di hacking tendo a
circondarmi di questi oggetti come
dicevamo quindi la mia paranoica
deformazione professionale mi porta a
chiedere ma se tutti questi oggetti non
fossero veramente così sicuri come
vorremmo credere quale sarebbe
probabilmente la vostra risposta a
questa domanda non è mio problema
importante che la televisione riesca a
collegarsi a internet a mostrare per
papig a mio figlio tenerlo buono mentre
lo scarico da youtube
in realtà questa domanda se la sono
posta tanti ricercatori tanti esperti di
sicurezza informatica la comunità e
hacking underground sono tutti molto
attenti a questo settore perché è un
campo con il quale bello misurarsi in
più la king di questi oggetti finisce
sulle prime pagine del giorno dei
giornali dei quotidiani che sono oggetti
che tanti di noi hanno in casa
pensate che gli ultimi attacchi
informatici sono stati eseguiti da reti
di frigoriferi lavatrici televisori per
mostrati reti di attacchi informatici
tutti con il benestare inconsapevole dei
loro proprietari che magari non hanno
neanche cambiato la password predefinita
dell'elettrodomestico
pensate magari adesso voi siete può
ascoltare ted da casa la vostra
lavatrice sta attaccando il sito del new
york times beh in realtà questo ancora
non è un mio problema magari interesse
alle aziende ma ancora non mi tocca
direttamente
allora parliamo di oggetti di uso
quotidiano che sono nelle nostre case
per esempio questi oggetti hanno le
nostre informazioni personali un
termostato conosce come dicevo prima in
che stanzia siamo magari dove siamo col
cellulare
la bilancia conosce quanto pesiamo
conosce anche quanti bicchieri d'acqua
abbiamo bevuto magari o lo smartphone
conosce il percorso abituale della
nostra corsetta di fitness serale sa
esattamente che percorso facciamo oppure
le mete come le televisioni
sono una vetrina di quello che avviene
in salotto o nella stanza di sopra
quindi questi dati sono molto importanti
se vanno a finire nelle mani sbagliate
potrebbe diventare pericoloso
beh questo inizia un po far vacillare la
nostra risposta iniziale
beh se vi dicessi che è possibile
modificare cartelli come questo a
distanza o semafori intelligenti
oppure pensate a una notizia di un paio
di mesi fa dove bmw e mini hanno dovuto
aggiornare sempre via internet
remotamente le loro automobili perché
tramite un'app sullo smartphone era
possibile aprire le portiere per esempio
sono addirittura ricercatori
dell'università di washington e di san
diego che sono riusciti a controllare a
distanza delle automobili con i sistemi
di controllo delle automobili quindi e
mostrare una velocità diversa sul
tachimetro oppure a gestire i freni
dell'automobile le luci quindi con un
rischio conseguente per chi si mette
alla guida
beh questo non è un mio problema
iniziale non regge più tanto e allora vi
ricordate il cardio stimolatore di cui
ho parlato all'inizio ci sono altri
ricercatori che sono riusciti a
collegarsi a questo cardio stimolatore
quindi a distanza cambiare i parametri
addirittura indurre la defibrillazione
non in un paziente vero per fortuna era
una prova di fronte a questo mio non è
un mio problema non regge proprio più
tornando alla nostra immagine iniziale
quella della toilette
il sistema di controllo di sicurezza del
bluetooth di questo cellulare di questa
tua letta impostata come 0000 capite che
è molto facile collegarsi quindi avreste
toilette e fare degli scherzi che li sta
utilizzando magari facciamo partire
oggetto del bidet facciamo partire
l'aria calda apriamo e chiudiamo il
coperchio quindi lacking può anche
essere molto divertente in alcuni casi a
questo punto dopo che avete visto queste
cose se io chiedessi la stessa domanda
iniziale ma se tutti questi oggetti non
fossero veramente così sicuri come
vorremmo credere come sarebbe diventata
ora la vostra risposta io spero che
adesso la risposta sia sì è un mio
problema devo fare qualcosa
e giusto che ci circondiamo
quotidianamente di oggetti di questo
tipo di nuove tecnologie senza però
perdere di vista i nuovi rischi ai quali
ci esponiamo e la centralità che abbiamo
noi
nel proteggerci da questi rischi prima e
dopo l'acquisto
nella scelta del prodotto e
nell'utilizzo del prodotto quindi cosa
possiamo fare noi concretamente da parte
nostra per proteggersi da queste cose ma
in primo luogo quanti di voi leggono i
manuali nessuno legge più manuali ormai
prodotti sono intuitivi e facili da
usare
siamo presi dall'entusiasmo del nuovo
acquisto non vogliamo leggere il manuale
eppure leggendo il manuale capiamo
esattamente quali sono le funzioni di
quel prodotto perché dobbiamo sapere che
cosa offre in primo luogo per capire che
cosa fa ma in secondo luogo per spegnere
tutto ciò che non ci serve è inutile
lasciare porte aperte dal quale poi gli
hacker possono intrufolarsi per esempio
è inutile tenere acceso il comando
vocale dalla vostra televisione in
salotto che di fatto attivo un microfono
nel vostro salotto
se sapete già che userete sempre
telecomando e importante poi dare solo
le informazioni private necessarie di
questi prodotti perché possono essere
sempre attaccati ai visti da qualcuno
per esempio un termostato che deve
collegarsi al meteo per cambiare la
temperatura di casa non deve sapere per
forza la vostra via e numero civico
dell'abitazione importante sapere la
città all cup
è poi importante anche tenere aggiornati
questi prodotti perché se vengono solo
installati mai più toccati le vecchie
versioni sono soggette errori di
programmazione sono soggette attacchi
che gli hacker possono utilizzare quindi
vanno tenuti costantemente aggiornati e
infine una un'accortezza tanto facile
quanto importante cambiare la password
ai propri dispositivi o almeno inserirne
una là dove prima non c'era come un
cellulare per esempio magari utilizziamo
anche una password complessa non
utilizziamo 123456 che tra l'altro già
vinto il premio nel 2014 come password
più utilizzata adesso lo sappiamo lo
sanno tutti tra l'altro adesso
quindi quello che io vorrei ottenere
oggi è che voi di fronte al prossimo
nuovo acquisto tecnologico vi chiediate
come faccio a fargli fare tutto quello
che voglio e subito dopo vi chiediate
come faccio a non farli fare tutto
quello che non voglio
grazie